dans l'atelier de mehdi garrigue pas un
bruit
sinon celui des ciseaux entre ses mains
expertes le visage d'une future
marionnettes modeler au gré des
accessoires en change donné on aimait un
oeil plus rang et à prendre un autre
personnage qui apparaît cela qu'avec une
une forme de tête qui est une forme de
cette ronde assez c'est assez basique on
va dire on peut avoir une multitude de
personnages et que l'imagination qui est
la limite
[Musique]
cela fait presque dix ans que ce tour on
joue à fait de la marionnette son métier
ici ils réalisent tout lui-même du
patronat jusqu'à la confection grâce à
sa minutie et à son savoir-faire compter
une centaine d'heures pour un seul
modèle
le trentenaire est aujourd'hui une
référence dans la profession
un véritable rêve d'enfant devenu
réalité en fait quand j'étais petit il y
avait beaucoup de programmes avec des
marionnettes à la télé on avait les
muppets jim henson on avait les
fragueules on avait
le bébête show les minikeums les
guignols enfin voilà les enfants les
rediff
donc en fait moi j'ai baigné là dedans
et j'ai été happé des petits par ça et
puis je crois je devais avoir 7 ans
quand j'ai fait ma première marionnette
qui ressemblait pas grand chose mais il
y avait quelque chose il y avait une
envie en tout cas elle n'est pas partie
voilà pourtant mehdi empruntera d'abord
d'autres chemins avant de créer son
entreprise
des études de gestion et de marketing
jusqu'au jour où ils contactent alain
duverne
le créateur des guignols de l'info alors
au sommet de leur succès elle m'a permis
pendant dix ans de venir dans son
atelier je suis allé au culot
j'y suis allé après l'avoir eu plusieurs
fois au téléphone et il m'a dit vas-y
regarde immo vers la porte et puis m'a
dit vas-y regard et puis du coup pendant
dix ans je suis allé dès que j'avais du
temps que j'avais des vacances j'avais
observé du coup en disant j'ai vu
énormément de choses dès lors tout
s'enchaîne et c'est en 2012 que la
carrière de mehdi garrigues va
littéralement décollé à l'époque il
assiste derrière son poste de télévision
au début d'un jeunes marionnettistes
très prometteur il s'appelle jeff pana
cloques et son compagnon de scène et à
un certain jean marc
on s'est rencontré à paris il avait déjà
une marionnette qui était une
marionnette qui l'avait achetée dans un
magasin de magie je crois et voilà en
fait il lui fallait une manette on va
dire plus professionnelle qui lui
permettent de ne plus jouer la comédie
qui le limite - dans son jeu et donc
voilà donc je suis intervenu à ce moment
là on a re design et jean-marc on a
amené tout un tas de choses pour qu' il
puisse jouer et utiliser pleinement son
talent depuis le duo comique a rempli
des zéniths et même fait le tour du
monde
une fierté pour mehdi garrigues qui
travaille toujours avec le comédien mais
également pour d'autres comme
l'humoriste jamel debbouze entre la
télévision le cinéma et le théâtre
une douzaine de marionnettes sortent
chaque année de la tv d'orange